[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 la
agenda de las mujeres es nuestra
prioridad y por eso en cada edición
denunciamos los derechos que no nos dan
y buscamos caminos hacia la igualdad esa
vocación la compartimos con unas mujeres
que este año convocó al foro generación
igualdad una reunión mundial por la
igualdad de género y centrada en la
sociedad civil el encuentro fue
organizado conjuntamente por los
gobiernos de méxico y de francia comenzó
en ciudad de méxico el 29 hasta el 31 de
marzo y culminará en parís del 30 de
junio al 2 de julio del 2021 el tema nos
interesa a todos
en lo que esperábamos una mujer estuvo
encerrada con su agresor en lo que
esperábamos una niña tuvo que dejar la
escuela en lo que esperábamos una madre
no comió por alimentar a sus hijos en el
año en el que todo paro los derechos de
las mujeres retrocedieron y el progreso
de años se deshizo así sin más
ahora que el mundo empieza a andar de
nuevo debemos empezar a actuar para una
mujer que de cada tres ha sufrido
violencia en su vida para las más de 47
millones de mujeres que están siendo
empujadas a la pobreza extrema por la
pandemia para el 50% de la población que
merece el 50 por ciento del poder
este año líderes y agentes de cambio se
reunirán en el foro generación igualdad
un foro para construir fortalecer los
derechos de las mujeres para las
próximas generaciones demostremos que
luchamos para que la igualdad avance y
en un año en el que es virtualmente
imposible que nos reunamos nos
reuniremos virtualmente no esperes es
momento de actuar por la igualdad hasta
que actuemos por la igualdad
están en ella soy la embajadora de
francia en colombia michelle jamis y la
representante de 1 mujeres en colombia
bibiana aído almagro bienvenidos a ambas
y vamos a empezar a conversar
viviana inició con usted el foro
generación igualdad será la reunión
feminista mundial más importante desde
1995 cuando se creó la plataforma de
beijing esa hoja de ruta que nos marcó
la agenda feminista y que se cumple muy
lentamente la pandemia desaceleró más la
lucha por la igualdad en ese contexto
cuál es la importancia del foro
generación igualdad que se cierra en
parís
sin duda es un buen momento para pasar
de la retórica histórica a la acción
decisiva porque lo que hemos visto tras
26 años desde que se adoptó la
plataforma de acción de beijing es que
la igualdad de género no es una realidad
en ninguna parte del mundo por tanto
este foro iniciado en mexico y que
culminará en parís es una oportunidad
para la acción para ese diálogo
intergeneracional entre las mujeres que
lideraron la agenda hace 26 años y las
generaciones de mujeres jóvenes que hoy
están gritando por la igualdad de género
por la paz por la justicia contra la
violencia sexual en tantos países del
mundo es un momento de juntar fuerzas de
trabajar por las coaliciones para la
acción de mover la agenda de la igualdad
de género de pedir una transformación no
sólo queremos la recuperación las
mujeres del mundo queremos una
transformación de un sistema patriarcal
que se ha mostrado claramente injusto e
ineficiente
embajadora de realizó y conmemoramos un
poco más de un cuarto de siglo de la
plataforma de acción de beijing este fue
un momento histórico para los derechos
humanos y el plan más completo a la
fecha sobre el empoderamiento femenino
en beijing más de 30.000 activistas y
representantes de 189 países prometieron
lograr la igualdad de derechos y de
oportunidades para las mujeres y las
niñas del planeta 26 años después desde
su propia experiencia usted como cree
que estamos
bueno nunca muchas gracias por invitarme
a este programa de jazz hoy yo creo que
lo que pasó en beijing hace 25 años
ahora 26 fue algo sin precedentes
pudimos lograr un resultado
extraordinario gracias al trabajo
conjunto de los gobiernos y de la
sociedad civil como usted lo dijo 30.000
militantes 26 años después hemos visto
progreso avances pero tenemos dos
fuerzas contra ellas dos enemigos los
progresos en las leyes en los tratados a
veces no se traducen en la realidad
entonces hay que haga que coincidimos en
la realidad con los tratados y el
segundo la segunda fuerza contraria son
los retrocesos los conservatismo que
cuestionan los derechos adquiridos para
las mujeres nunca es totalmente
adquirido un derecho y tenemos que
luchar contra esta estos vientos
contrarios yo creo que la cumbre que se
va a llevar a cabo a finales de este mes
el mes en parís va a ser un gran momento
de multilateralismo
vamos a trabajar con la sociedad civil
va a ser una alianza para hacer un
balance de lo que se ha hecho de lo que
se ha perdido y permitir nuevos nuevos
resultados concretos los estados van a
llegar con promesas con compromisos para
hacer un nuevo salto para adelante
hablemos de esos resultados concretos
bibiana se espera que en parís se
anuncien las iniciativas por la igualdad
para al menos los siguientes cinco años
por venir como se alterara la agenda de
las mujeres y de no es un adelanto de lo
que se va a decir
bueno lo importante es asumir compromiso
para la acción yo creo que es obvio que
ninguna parte del mundo se ha conseguido
la igualdad que lamentablemente la
pandemia ha estado de manera
desproporcionada a las mujeres se ha
incrementado la violencia de género de
una manera sustancial hemos visto como
las mujeres han caído más en el
desempleo porque están empleadas en los
sectores que han sido más afectados por
la cob y 19 hemos visto también una
sobrecarga del trabajo de cuidado no
remunerado que recae principalmente
sobre las mujeres el cierre de las
escuelas ha provocado
que las mujeres tengan que hacer de
tutora de maestra la saturación de los
sistemas hospitalarios que tengan que
estar al cuidado de las personas
enfermas de las personas dependientes y
ella había una sobrecarga del trabajo de
cuidado no remunerado sobre las mujeres
sin duda la pandemia la ha incrementado
por eso es importante acelerar la agenda
para la igualdad de género y para ello
son necesarios compromisos políticos
compromiso financiero compromisos
económicos hacen falta recursos para
avanzar esta agenda y en parís veremos
alrededor de 6 coaliciones para la
acción la primera relativa a la
violencia de género y a medidas
específicas para eliminar esta forma de
violencia que azota a las mujeres en
todo el mundo por supuesto hablar
avanzar en derechos económicos y en
justicia económica una tercera
relacionada con la salud sexual y
reproductiva la cuarta condición para la
acción es la acción feminista para la
justicia climática una quinta
relacionada con la tecnología y la
innovación para la igualdad de género
porque sigue habiendo brechas digitales
de enormes que en contextos como este de
la pandemia se han hecho más visible que
nunca
y hay que eliminar esa brecha hay que
dar la oportunidad a las niñas para que
desde pequeña se involucren en las stem
y la sexta área la sexta coalición para
la acción es la relativa a los
movimientos feministas y al necesario
apoyo que hay que darles para que sigan
transformando la agenda igualdad de
género para que sigamos avanzando de
manera conjunta
y es que estamos lejos pero lejísimos
onu-mujeres promueve la generación de
igualdad y ciertamente esa generación no
es ésta difícilmente será la siguiente
michelle la igualdad para cuando cuantos
años nos faltan para dejar de ser
ciudadanas de segunda clase
no lo sabemos pero que hay que decir que
desde la segunda parte del siglo xxi
hemos hecho muchos más avances que
durante los siglos anteriores entonces
yo soy una optimista yo creo que esta
cumbre es una oportunidad extraordinaria
y además llega un momento muy oportuno
como bien lo dijo la representante de
onu-mujeres viviana está esta cumbre se
tenía que llevar a cabo el año pasado en
julio pero por la pandemia se postergó y
yo creo que es mucho más importante que
tenga lugar ahora porque la pandemia
reveló los obstáculos sistémicos a la
igualdad de género
las mujeres fueron mucho más afectadas
que antes de la crisis desempleo
violencia doméstica y yo creo que esta
crisis finalmente fue como un revelador
que va a permitir a esta cumbre ser
mucho más eficiente es difícil prever el
plazo en el cual los procesos van a ser
realidad pero avanzamos hacemos dos
pases para pasos para adelante pasa para
atrás pero avanzamos yo soy un activista
con la voluntad política podemos tener
éxito y lo más importante tener el apoyo
de la popular de la población masculina
no es posible que las mujeres muchachos
luchen solas hay que tener una fuerza
para compartir este objetivo para que
todo el mundo no se den cuenta de la
necesidad de tener una sociedad mixta
gracias a embajadora y usted ha
mencionado bibiana ya varias veces en
esta entrevista de la crisis de kobe 19
la crisis de igualdad de género está
exacerbada por la pandemia la inversión
en los derechos de las mujeres se volvió
más urgente si es que cabe decirlo ese
fue uno de los temas en el inicio del
foro en mexico y entonces
le quiero preguntar para usted cuáles
son esas áreas de inversión que son
prioritarias muy rápidamente
pues hacen falta recursos para avanzar
la agenda y como bien decía la
embajadora que nos involucremos no solo
las mujeres de las diferentes
generaciones sino también los hombres
esto no puede ser una lucha de mujeres
contra hombres sino una lucha de mujeres
y hombres contra un sistema que se ha
mostrado claramente injusto e
ineficiente las mujeres del mundo
queremos una nueva normalidad queremos
una transformación no queremos volver a
la vieja normalidad porque realmente no
pensamos que la violencia de género
tenga que ser considerado lo normal que
las brechas salariales sean considerada
lo normal que el hecho de que los
cuidados recaigan exclusivamente sobre
las mujeres sea algo normal que la
discriminación por el sexo con el que
hayas nacido sea parte de lo normal
queremos una nueva normalidad que nos
lleve a un sistema social más justo más
incluyente y yo creo que también más
eficiente para para todas y para todos y
es que no nos hemos cansado de decirlo
en este programa que el feminismo no es
una lucha para poner a las mujeres por
encima sino una lucha de derechos
humanos para que seamos iguales y para
que tenemos acceso tengamos acceso a
mismos derechos y las mismas
posibilidades que los hombres muchísimas
gracias son las voces de los
representantes organizadores del foro
para la equidad que tendrá lugar en
julio en parís en la embajada de francia
en colombia y también onu mujeres en
colombia que hablaron para ellas hoy y
ya para el cierre después de ese
agradecimiento en 25 años hemos avanzado
sí pero a ritmo de tortuga la
representación política de las mujeres
se duplicó pero aún así sólo una de cada
cuatro parlamentarias es mujeres y
empresarialmente en 2019 fue el récord
de más mujeres si os pero el cuadro
completo es de 500 firmas líderes en el
mundo y con solamente menos del 7 por
ciento de mujeres en la esencia y la
cultura más de 900 personas se ganaron
el nobel hasta ahora sólo 53 son mujeres
y así podríamos seguir todo el día que
esta sea la oportunidad para revitalizar
los esfuerzos por un futuro que sea
feminista gracias a las embajadoras y a
nuestros televidentes nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]